avant d'avoir un siège trouve ça
complètement extravagant tout ce que
tout le monde achetait pour les chiens
mais maintenant on est justement en du
gaillard est tellement j'aime tellement
que c'est quasiment un membre de la
famille pour moi c'est vraiment stupide
à dire mais vraiment genre oui et
beaucoup de choses extravagantes et
normalement quand je prends un petit de
reculer quand je regarde de loin je
réalise que par exemple lui offrir genre
qu'on l'ait mais on la mène à l'autel
par exemple dire ok une période de jeu
ou période qu'alain de 30 mai ne cesse
un peu extravagant c'est un peu
considéré un peu comme un être humain un
chien mais à part de sun un hôtel pour
chiens par exemple
ouais ouais ouais mais oui petit comme
des fois se passer des séances qu'alain
de 30 minutes ça s'est un peu
extravagant mais non on n'est jamais
pris mais ça on aurait pu prendre des
bons son genre est ce qu'on prend 30
minutes
câlins pour pincho non mais si c'est
vraiment oui des fois j'ai j'assume
totalement qu'il y ait des dépenses
extravagantes mais je suis obnubilé par
lui donc je vis avec moi je vais être en
retard pour son anniversaire on l'a
gâtée mais je veux dire à part de ça on
lui donnerait calais nous mêmes